Awesome.
So joining us today,
we're so privileged to welcome Alicia
Reiner who can currently being seen in
season four of orange is the new black
as fig a role which one her a sag award
she connects be seen bringing her towns
to other shows including masters of sex
and the new FX series.
Better things.
Equity was Alicia's seventh independent
features shot in 2015 but the first as
both actress and producer.
Welcome.
Next we have actress, producer
and writer Sarah, Megan Thomas,
who was on a mission to tell stories
about strong and complex women. She wrote,
produced and starred in
the movie backwards and has
cofounded the company broad
street pictures along with Alicia with
equity as their inaugural project.
She's an advocate for charitable causes,
most notably minding your mind,
a charity that educates children in
school about mental health problems to
alleve the stigma.
Okay,
actress and a gun is a two time Emmy
award winner for her performance as Skylar
white on breaking bad.
She's awesome.
So Woo,
let's start.
And numerous other television shows.
Movies in live theater is
such as deadwood, gracepoint,
enemy of the state and many, many
more. She connects, be seen and clique,
Clint Eastwood's,
Sally and on television in the second
season of shades of blue with Jennifer
Lopez.
Welcome
writer Amy Fox,
a fellow Brooklynite woo has over a
dozen theater productions and a merchant
ivory film credit to her name due
to her crisp and quirky writing.
She's been called a ferocious talent and
in 2000 she was commissioned to bring
her play heights to the big
screen starring greats such
as Glenn Close and James
Marsden,
welcome
Violin Mira men and was recently selected
to be a fellow at 20th Century Fox is
global directors initiative.
She's been awarded the Nora Ephron prize
for a groundbreaking woman filmmaker by
Tribeca Film Festival and Vogue magazine
and she's also been selected by Glamour
magazine as one of the 35 women
under 35 running Hollywood.
Ooh,
excellent.
So thank you all so much for being here.
I think it would be great if you could
each quickly just introduce your role on
the film and why this project
was so personally important
to you. To be a part of
hi. Oh, hey. Um, I'm Aleisha. Um,
so I have,
I guess I have a story by credit because
Sarah and I developed the treatment and
then hired the amazing
Amy Fox to write it. Um,
and Sarah and I produced it.
And then I'm also in the film
and I just need to say like,
I just heard that intro and it's the
first time we've all been together and I
want to cry because I'm just so grateful
to be like part of this amazing group
of women who like have
these incredible resumes.
And you know,
I guess my interest in the film was how
do we make the world better for women?
Like that's really my truth.
Um,
and how do we tell stories that sometimes
other people are afraid to tell about
the stuff that's not okay.
Um,
and in this case,
how women are treated sometimes
on Wall Street is that story.
Hi,
I'm Sarah and I think Alicia did a great
intro and on our involvement in the
film, um, my character in the film is,
is a woman named Aaron
Manning. And, um, um,
she particularly has a place in my heart
because she's a woman trying to have it
all and,
and someone who enters the corporate
world thinking she can't have it all and
she's,
I'm pregnant and hiding it and dealing
with a home life and a work life and
realizing that maybe she won't get to
where she thinks she can in her career.
And I think personally, um,
I can really relate to, uh,
maybe not being in your career where you
think you will be at a certain age or a
certain time point like when
you choose to start a family.
So I hope that she's a character that
kind of resonates with a lot of young
women out there who are thinking about
being powerful women and also starting a
family.
Okay.
Um,
I'm Anna Gunn.
I play Naomi Bishop and I was
just in love with the film.
As soon as I read it.
I,
I thought that the story of three
women who are leading the way in,
in terms of the storytelling
and the nuance, the detail,
um,
the layers to each of the characters.
And especially I was
looking for a character,
very much like this one who is
not a reactor towards a man,
but it's really in the forefront and is
the one moving the action forward as as
are my lovely co stars
and producers. And, um,
I really was intrigued by the
fact that she's devoted her life.
And just as,
as you said about Aaron,
there is that question of
the sacrifices you make,
the things that you take on or give up
in order to get what you want and to,
to succeed.
And I was fascinated with a woman
as confident and strong as she is,
who's been on a winning streak.
And then when we meet her though,
she suddenly had her first real loss and
she's struggling then for the rest of
the film to get back up.
And,
and it gives her a different perspective
completely on the life that she's led
so far.
I, um, yeah, I had actually worked
with Sarah Alicia previously
in theater as a playwright. And
so when they approached me, um,
and they had founded the company and had
this concept of a Wall Street film with
these three women
characters, um, I was, I was,
it appealed to me immediately and I
don't have any background in finance. Um,
the original Wall Street movie
was one of my favorite movies,
which is an odd fact that people
wouldn't necessarily expect that from me.
But it's true that a, I just always
loved the right, it took you out.
I loved the ethical questions and that
maybe the questions of family loyalty and
kind of how greed,
the interfaces at that end to the idea
of taking that genre and then putting
this new perspective on it and also
telling the truths of the women. I mean,
we interviewed so many women who was
experienced as you'll see in the film and
the idea that these, these women have
been working on Wall Street for 30 years,
20 years, 10 years, and we haven't
seen their stories anywhere.
And that the big part of my goal as a
storyteller is to uncover stories and tell
stories that we should, we should have
seen these women before, but we haven't.
So here they are. Um,
and I directed the film.
I, I mean, I just wanted to do it
from the moment I read the script,
thought Amy's writing had this like kind
of sophistication and elegance and kind
of provoked us, uh, kind of, uh,
kind of precise approach to filmmaking
that I was really inspired by. And a,
and I was really inspired by this, the
main character as Amy wrote her. I mean,
Naomi was someone I kind
of had never kind of,
I think seen on screen before and I knew
a dialogue with this character with the
right kind of mind and body behind it
would be a conversation I could grow from
as well
as a woman myself.
Yeah.
That's excellent.
So quickly from the audience.
I'd love to get a show of hands form,
um,
the folks in the room and for the
men specifically, I'm curious,
how many times in your career have you
felt like either personal or professional
relationship has suffered because
you've been too career focused?
Okay.
How about for the women?
We got some shy folks out here
come if feel wavering hands.
We're not sure if that's why it fell.
Yeah, I'll raise my hand. Hi. Um,
it's clear that this character is
so strong and driven and ambitious.
Can you talk a little bit about what
it was like preparing for that role and
either personal or other interviews
that you did to pull from?
Well, I first talked with Mira for, um,
a couple of hours I think.
And we were really on the same page from
the get go in terms of the warrior that
this woman is and the
sacrifices that she has made.
She has chosen to, and it's very
clearly spelled out there. Um,
she does what she does. She, she took
it on out of need in the beginning.
And then I think the, the, the winning,
the art of the deal and the win,
um, is something that is insane. It's an,
it's incredibly addictive.
And I talked to then Alicia and Sarah,
they gave me so much information about
the women that they had interviewed,
the women who were the inspiration
for these roles and also investors.
And then I was on the
phone with Barbara Byrne,
who is a Wall Street luminary and she
was wonderful and I took reams of notes
and she really let me understand her
journey difficulties, the struggles,
sacrifices, and also the
victories and what really put,
she has such a joy in terms in
such a passion for what she does.
So, um, we then had a day in New York
before we started shooting in Philly.
Um, and we, we went through a mock
IPO so I could, I felt like we,
I could really wrap my head around it then
and then going out to dinner with, um,
a variety of women and just watching the
interaction and the razor sharp wit and,
um,
incredible intellect and fun
and laughter and strength.
And so I took pieces from,
from all of that. And um,
I also felt like, you know,
with good writing, the, the,
the hints are there, the, the,
the meat is there. So there were,
and I liked the fact that,
you know,
that she doesn't see her family very
often and it's not leaned on too much.
It's not, you know, heavily, but it's,
but it's there and she really has,
she has her fish and she has her mentor,
John and I think even her boyfriend,
she is wanting to have a close
and intimate relationship,
but there's always a sense of perhaps
there's a trust issue there. So,
um,
well that sounds together. Yeah. And we'll
say a little bit of that later as well.
Just kind of the importance of building
a network that you can trust on and yeah,
kind of at what costs. Right.
Um, excellent. Um, Amy, you know,
I think at,
you know,
at Google we talk a lot about being
kinder to ourselves and kind of quieting
what we call this inner saboteurs.
So you have this little person
talking in the back of your head.
I want to work at Google. What's that?
It just happened to talk about it here.
Um, in the film, the characters briefly
discuss, I'm not giving anything away,
but they did briefly discuss the
differences in how men and women digest
feedback. Why was it important to you to
include that conversation in the film?
Um,
I think for
me personally, it was an aspect of the
story that I really, really related to.
I think, um, I, so as I was
interviewing people, um,
this theme kept coming up again and
again where women would say that if
something went wrong, if
the, if a deal went wrong, if
something didn't go through,
they,
they would be very hard on themselves.
They would sort of stay up nights
questioning why did that happen?
And men and women told me that men
are less likely to do that. Not,
not that they never do that,
but that men are more likely
to get pissed off and say, oh,
that didn't work out because of this
happened or that and blaming something
outside of themselves where women
will turn it inwards. And that's,
I guess I just personally have been very
aware of in my own life and I've taught
writing for 10 years.
I see a big difference in my male and
female students with that voice you're
talking about. I see it in my daughter
already. Um, I don't know why that is.
I don't know why that, that Sabbath
to her seems to be stronger and women,
but it's something I'm very passionate
about dispelling whenever I can.
So that seems really important to me.
Yeah,
I think it's interesting because it does,
the inner saboteurs can also
be such a strength, right?
To Gut check yourself and
keep yourself in line.
And I think we're starting to see a turn
of weighing a bit more on some of the Q
values versus Iq and making
sure that we find that line. Um,
we actually have another clip
and we see Aaron in the scene.
Basically mustering all the courage and
guts that she can to blurt out that one
sentence.
Um,
and I know how tough that is because I've
actually done it that they're the same
thing. Um, and get
completely shut down. Um,
can you talk to us a little bit about
what you think you've seen in the
workplace where women can help other
women and pick them up from these places?
Yeah, I mean, I think in general,
women don't go in there and do what
Erin does in that scene. Enough ask,
ask for that job promotion even,
even if you do get to know. Um,
and one of the things we really wanted
to explore in that scene between me and
Anna and both our characters is how
difficult it is to be women of different
generations and how Ana's character isn't
really, and I'll let you speak to that,
but from,
from my standpoint as Erin,
I don't see that she's overwhelmed with
her work at this time and she feels like
there's not enough, um, spots at the top.
I'm only seeing it as my bosses
shutting me down. So we were also in,
I'll let you talk a little a bit to this,
but interested in the dynamic between
the two women when you want a promotion.
Yeah. We talked that scene
was a really intricate and,
and very difficult seeing really because,
um,
because I think that we establish a
backstory that Naomi was actually very
supportive and, and brought Aaron in
and nurtured her and moved her along.
And actually one of the things that
the women, um, emphasized a lot,
the women that I spoke to, um,
was that it was very important.
The mentor mentee relationship is
extremely important. And the, the,
the having somebody bring you in and
bring you along and help you along.
And then in turn when it's, when
it's, when you get to a certain point,
it's your turn then to
mentor somebody else.
And they also said that it was
extremely important to know that,
that you had somebody, one person at
least who had your back and vice versa,
that you could count on in a crunch.
And I think that Naomi really feels
that way about Erin, but she's got,
right now she's just,
you know,
experienced this failure and it's just
been splashed all over the television.
She's just dealing,
um,
I don't know if she's actually dealt
with their boss at that point yet,
but she's,
she's looking,
she's so intent and she's so intense
about looking for the next deal and the
next win and making sure
that she doesn't slip away.
And so when she says it's not the time,
she's not trying to be mean,
and she's not trying to be dismissive,
she's just saying this is the reality.
And she's a person who
just speaks her mind very,
very honestly,
and she doesn't mince words.
And so it's not meant to be a get
out of here. It's meant to be,
look at this place as a mass. We're
all, you know, it's a, it's a,
we're all in some sort of jeopardy. And
when the time is right, she, she means it.
She really means it. So that you know,
she does say what she really gives Naomi,
gives her boss later tells her,
tells him that um,
Aaron did wonderful work and so
she is looking to help her along.
But there's there is that
misinterpretation, the kind of things.
Yeah and the misinterpreting of certain
things that are said and wondering does
somebody really have my back because this
is such a competitive environment and
I just want to add one thing cause it
was a relative to what we were just
talking about. Women internalize it
more. So Aaron's the know from Naomi,
Erin's internalizing is I'm a failure
as opposed to the timing's bad.
And that goes back to what we're saying.
Like if a man gets a no,
they might bounce back more quickly
and go ask for it again a little later.
And interestingly enough,
in reference to film
making in the edit room,
we played a lot with what order to put
the scenes and do we put Naomi asking for
her promotion first or Aaron asking
first and they told different stories
because in fact they're both
trying for the same thing.
And there is that fear.
And that competition because there is
that feeling because there are so many,
so few women in this world
of there's not enough space.
Um, and that's, you know, part of
the story we were trying to tell.
That's okay.
It's, it's definitely, um,
something that we, you know,
you're competing for the same types of
projects in this time type of recognition.
And uh, our CFO, Ruth Porat who
actually came from Wall Street,
um,
she has shared with us in multiple
different formats that the communication
styles between men and
women are different.
That men will go in and
I want this promotion.
And not all men just for the sake of,
I'm generalizing here,
but um, where women, when
they say something like that,
you have to assume either as a male or
a female boss at they are shouting it
from the mountain top.
Even that one sentence,
is this the right time for a promotion?
She is screaming that she's ready. Um,
so I think, you know, for,
for all everyone in this room
who can help people get there,
it's important to know that those
communication styles really matter.
Okay. I just want to jump in. I'm
only just, I think about 10 days ago,
there was an article in the New York
Times about advice for women asking for a
raise or promotion.
Um,
and I actually thought it was an
onion article when I saw it because it
literally was instructing women on how
to do a dance so they wouldn't appear
threatening and asking
for what they deserve.
And there was no acknowledgement that
maybe they need to be heard differently,
that the person doing the, with the power
it needs, it was literally like, well,
you don't want your boss
to think you're demanding.
And this was in the New
York Times about a week ago.
So I just feel like there's so much
progress to be made on this issue.
And actually, I mean, when it comes
to, when it comes to this scene, um,
the other detail that I find interesting
is that outfit that Sarah is wearing is
a, is a kind of a type of kind of, um,
an outfit that she kind of had scouted
out during this mock IPO that they
actually experienced.
And it was very specific.
There's kind of a schoolgirl quality to
that outfit that doesn't really kind of
progress past the point of kind
of seeing her in this moment.
But it really informed kind of how she
set up in that moment when she's asking
for that promotion and kind of the optics
of what you choose to wear in a work
environment was something we discussed
across the board with all of these
characters.
But that was very specific that that was
the outfit that she was going to wear
on that day that she was going
to ask for that promotion.
Can I add one tiny thing that brings
it back to Google in a way, which is,
I dunno if you guys know this,
but at the United States of women they
did a hackathon about creating apps to
help women ask for more
pay and they're like,
there was an article,
I think it was,
I'm trying to remember in the Wall
Street Journal a couple of weeks ago and
there are these like seven new apps
all about how do we hack the pay gap?
Um, and I just find that it really
interesting that there are all these new
technological tools for people
to make change this way.
Yeah.
It's, you know, when not
touching a ton on the pay gap,
but it's something that,
um,
Laszlo Bock who was one of our
executives just released a op Ed, um,
publicly that there is no pay gap
across genders at Google, which I mean,
in my 12 years I go,
well,
that was my proudest moment and I was
almost in tears reading it just to give me
the peace of mine that we've
looked at this, come back to work,
don't think about it.
Just move that off your plate.
And it's one of those things where I hope
Google is leading the way to get some
of those data points out there and make
a real difference. So, um, excellent.
So we have one more clip for you.
Let's go ahead and cue it up.
I think we can tag line. This
one is, it's lonely at the top,
setting up for a drink with a
girlfriend to catch up. Um, you know,
I think it's tough. We, there's the,
the underlying here where you kind of
are seeing your character who's very
strong and powerful and ambitious and,
uh,
letting her guard down for the first
time and just looking for, you know,
some human connection and
having some time with somebody.
And then she very quickly realizes that
she's being taken advantage of. Um,
and I,
you know,
I think this scene is also interesting
because we see two women who were both
driven and both ambitious and going
after their same goals. And, um,
I'm curious for any of the,
kind of the point of how we balance this
line of being successful and driven and
ambitious and firm and decisive,
but also vulnerable enough and maybe
showcasing qualities that we're not proud
of or that we may not aspire to or we
don't want to admit we're capable of.
And how do we balance that?
Um,
so tell me maybe as a director or
writer or any of the actresses kind of,
do you guys have answers
that I am all ears
and it's more of a
statement than a question.
Yeah. Any thoughts on, you know,
it's funny when I watched that scene
high, watch it as the carrot, you know,
I'm still very connected to
that human and that human.
I like I had to play the scene
as I'm protecting my friend.
Like that's how I found my way mentally.
And HeartWise is like I want to take,
I want to like take care of her
and if she's with a shitty guy,
I want to help her out of
that. And that's, uh, I,
that's not how the scene is experienced
and I fully understand that,
but that's sort of it.
It's interesting to me personally that
it's like we have these rationalizations
that we believe so deeply in that
sometimes we do hurt someone thinking that
we're trying to protect them.
Um,
that's life.
And that's to me,
one of the things from the beginning
when Sarah and I were first talking about
this movie,
about like these gray lines and,
and what is moral and what is
right and how do you show that?
Um,
and I think Amy did a
spectacular job aided by MIRA in,
in really sort of presenting these things.
And then letting audiences,
experiencing them and have
bothered to talk about,
but I don't, I guess to sum up,
yeah, I don't have an answer.
I really don't. Um, I think it,
we wanted to present it as a,
as a point of discussion.
I don't want to, it's rather maybe,
maybe Anna will. All right here we are.
But I think again,
and again as we were talking about this
movie and interviewing wall streeters,
what came up was it the women in business,
whether it's Wall Street entertainment,
you name it,
are either too nice or too tough.
They rub people the wrong way or whether
the nice girl that can get walked all
over and it doesn't get paid.
Um,
and I think that's actually
sadly still true to life.
I find myself sometimes being too tough
on people and then I go the reverse and
try and be too nice. And it's like,
and I'm constantly as a producer,
actress thinking about it and I
shouldn't have to. Um, but I am. Um,
and then, and I think women, you know,
men when they're in a tough situation,
they're going to tell you like it is,
they're going to tell you like it is
like this and you're going to listen to
them and blah blah blah. But if I talk
to you like that as a woman, it's like,
oh well maybe I should smile a little.
And so I think it's something I'm like,
I don't think, I don't know
how to solve it. It's sad.
Yeah. I think that's, that was something
that hit home so hard for me was the,
was the fact that they did that,
that,
that there is that walking the tight
rope of being too tough or too soft and
either one is going to get you, you know,
in trouble in some ways. And so it's,
it's almost like being on a
tight rope, you know, how to you,
and I remember Barbara Burns saying
that reading people and understanding
people, psychology and
understanding what the client needs,
understanding what your boss needs,
understanding.
But it's something that women I think
have to think about much more in terms of,
like you say, how you present
yourself, how you cope.
Go in and ask for a promotion,
how you have a discussion with your
client about pricing something when he
thinks it should be higher. And you
think in reality it should be lower.
But you gotta you gotta be careful,
especially when you've been told that
your ruffling feathers and rubbing people
the wrong way. And when doubt starts
to creep in, that's, you know,
that starts to erode the
person who, you know, Naomi,
who has been,
I think just like a shark sometimes
moving forward in these waters and really,
um, just really not afraid, frankly.
I think she's just pushed a lot of stuff
down and when the doubt starts to creep
in, that's when things
started to crumble. And again,
I think she really is, it's, it's a,
it's a moment when the bottom kind of
drops out when she thinks that she is,
you know,
I don't think she really has,
she doesn't have time
to have many friends,
which just is a very solitary person
because she's so focused and she is a
person who I think has,
has,
has closed a part of herself off and
closer part of herself down. So that,
you know, in this conversation it's,
it starts to be, it starts to feel,
I think like things are just falling
apart around her and she's really looking
for somebody or something
to hold on to. Yeah. So
as I think about it in here, like
just, just talk about it more. It,
it is strange that it has to be something
that a woman is held liable for it
because it feels like a super power
that you are capable of both of getting
things done and being
someone's best friend.
That kind of capacity for empathetic
leadership feels particularly like a
particularly female capability
that should be rewarded. Yeah.
And Yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm actually
[inaudible] this point, you know, I,
when I was doing the research and
getting prepared for today, um, I,
I couldn't believe it and I tried to
fact check it like 18 different times,
but that Kathryn Bigelow is the first
and only woman to win an academy award as
best director in 88 academy awards.
Um,
can you talk a little bit,
we talked earlier about mentors and
trying to find people to help you navigate
your career or build yourself up and
those times when it feels like it's
crumbling around you, how have you
navigated your career in that way?
Well,
it's kind of laterally because I see
more and more women kind of like kind of
younger generations, uh, taking, you know,
kind of creating situations for themselves
to direct when not when, you know,
in face of,
you know,
the lack of permission or kind of the
gatekeeper is allowing them to occupy
those positions. So I
find there's a, you know,
a number of women that kind of have made
their name in independent film making
as directors that I turned
to that are kind of,
we're kind of trying to come up together
and then we kind of try and form this
kind of peer to peer
mentorship with one another.
In terms of mentors that I had
kind of through kind of, you know,
the process of just learning
to become a filmmaker. Yeah.
More often than not they were men.
They were male directors that I had as
faculty and my film school program or
just people that I shadowed with or yeah,
more often than not because there are
so foot few women in that position they
would be men.
But I do find there to be some kind
of optimism and when I look sideways,
yeah. Yes. Well I think, you know, a big,
a big theme for me in the film
and then sort of looking at, um,
women in the creative world as well
as the idea of, of scarcity, right.
And the idea that it,
it requires someone to feel secure
and powerful in order to be generous.
So I think that is why so many mentors
in Wall Street and in the arts as well
have been men because you have to not
feel that your own position is in jeopardy
in order to reach down
and help someone else.
And just in doing press for the film,
um,
I had a memory that I hadn't
thought of in a long time.
And when I first moved to New York about
20 years ago when I started out as a
playwright and Tina Howe who was
a pilates or prize winning writer,
came and spoke at a conference
I was at for women playwrights.
And she actually got up and she said,
kind of the counter what you're saying.
And it didn't sound very inspiring
and all she said, um, yeah,
don't look at us up here to help you
because we barely have jobs are so, um,
and she said,
look to each other.
And it's funny thinking back on
it because in a way she was right.
And those are the people that have
helped me the most. Like, you know,
you've been with the three of us all
started out around the same time. Um,
but there's also something
very sad about that.
Very sad that a woman who had won
the Pulitzer prize basically said,
don't ask me for anything. My
own stature here is so shaky. Um,
and just for me doing the film,
looking at the difference between the
business world and the arts world,
it's also been interesting
because in the business world,
even though someone at the top may
not feel secure in their position,
they at least have resources at
their disposal in the arts.
I find there's such a scarcity
of resources that people
are even more likely to
look out for themselves and not reach
out to help someone else. So it's,
it's been very interest.
Um,
I want to make sure we have some time.
If anybody in the audience has questions.
We have Mike set up on either side.
MMM.
In the meantime,
I'll throw out another question while
people are getting up and thinking of
their questions. But, um,
I don't know if you guys had read and
I've been talking a lot about New York
Times articles up here.
Um,
but there was one about one about equity
that was in the RST. Exactly. Okay.
Um, there was one about brotalk on
Wall Street a couple of weeks ago. Um,
and it was for those of you
that haven't read it, it's, um,
basically was saying that,
you know,
in it behind closed doors or just
when you're not in mixed company,
that there's a lot of brotalk that
happens on Wall Street where there's,
you know, they're objectifying women and
how does this impact women's careers?
And, um, I don't think it's specific
to Wall Street. Right. Again,
that's a resonating theme
throughout this movie.
This is not just one particular industry.
It's a story in a perspective we haven't
seen before. Um, but I'm curious,
you know,
for the men in this room and
men in business or Hollywood,
they will be responsible for helping
to sponsor us to get us there because
they're in the positions of power.
Um,
so what are your thoughts on ways that
men can help to sponsor women if it's not
a direct mentorship or it's not
women that they're looking to?
Any examples of men that have really
helped you guys around your careers are
helpful with the film?
I mean, I will say that with my first
film, the investors were 90% men. Uh,
and I had no track record and
um, they didn't need the, um,
I find that sometimes fee, and this is
not good or bad, it's just different.
Sometimes female investors have a
little more of the herd mentality,
so they're more interested if
their friends have invested,
they're more interested in how
much they're friends who invested.
Where I find personally that the male
investors decide to believe in you and
they believe in you.
They write a check for whatever
they want to write a check for.
But I think it's just important that
we're 50% of the population and that
whether it's a man or a
woman in a position of power,
that we realize that big changes have to
be made in terms of bringing women up,
supporting women who want to have families
and want to go away for a year or two.
That doesn't mean they're not valuable.
They still have 30 or 40 years left of
working. Um, but making it a mission,
you know, much like we need
to make diversity a mission.
Like making it a mandate
that every company
and holding people accountable.
So that's another thing that Ruth brought
a over to us in terms of hiring and
promotion and just making sure that,
you know,
if there's not enough women on the dock
are not enough women being talked about
in talent reviews,
that we are asking pointed questions and
making sure that we're holding people
accountable to those conversations.
Um, go ahead and move a question. Okay.
Hi Guys. Thank you again so much
for coming. This is such a treat.
I was curious if you
could tell from the clips.
There are a lot of really powerful in
the film. And I was wondering, uh, if,
if you guys would like to talk about any
moments that were really fun to film or
to write or to direct,
that will kind of stick with you as
you move forward to other projects.
Um,
and if any of them really resonated for
you personally or just like a really fun
part of the film to work on.
Yeah. Like I feel like I loved every
single scene and just, I, I just,
it was everything.
The thing was just so meaty and juicy
and there was so much to sink my teeth
into. And, um, I, I, the,
the money speech I thought was
incredibly written. And also,
you know,
we talked a lot about finding
a balance in there because she,
Naomi, as much as she makes that
statement, she's not making it. It's not,
she's not the Gordon Gekko, she's not,
you know, she's not talking about grief,
but she is saying this is important and
we deserve to have this and to own it
and to stand up as much as men do.
And not to be afraid of it. Um,
and I just am sort of jumping
back to in terms of, you know,
what men can do to bring
women up or you know,
how it is that we can support each other.
I guess I was really lucky. I had to, um,
mentors myself who were,
um,
Kim Stanley and Vivian Mason
who were from the actors studio.
And they really gave me the sense that
I could do anything if I put my mind to
it. It might be hard, it might be years to
get there, but it was, you know, it was,
if you love it,
you just keep going and you keep doing
it and you work in a 99 seat theater in
La if that's what you need to do.
And you just keep,
keep feeding it and keep honing it.
And so that really did that.
Their support and their belief kept me
going through the lean times at the times
when I thought maybe this isn't gonna
work out. And I think that, again,
that's something that is explored
in this film and I think it's very,
very important for us to, to look at
it and to keep shining light on it.
Because I want my daughters to be,
to feel like they can do that,
that they,
that they feel like they have every
opportunity that a man has and they should
feel that they can go in and not be
afraid to ask for the promotion to ask for
what they want and to,
and to speak their mind.
Hm.
I mean,
I'd say any scene I got to see James
Purefoy and Anna just act off each other
who just like delightful chemistry and
like you guys are like a kind of classic
old Hollywood like Clark Gable,
like Lumbar,
like you guys just had that sharpness
with each other and James isn't too bad to
look at. It's not too bad to look
at it. For me, there's this magic,
I'm actually a very,
um,
concerned about the wrong personality
type for a writer because I'm very social
person and writing requires for you to
be alone in your house for Jensen time.
Do I have always starting
out in the theater.
My favorite moments are always when the
thing that you've created alone and you
know, you get in your head
and you're thinking, I mean,
I don't know if it's like coding,
but you're thinking like,
does anyone care about this thing I'm
writing? And then it becomes a reality.
So for me, when I first, the first
time I was able to come on set and, uh,
they were shooting some scenes and ana
department and there was this fish and I
just remembered sitting at my computer
one day and going like, you know, she,
we had talked about it, but
I just remember like, oh,
she should have a fish and the fish
is swimming. And you think like,
I'm spending my whole morning thinking
about this imaginary fish. Like,
but then you go on set and there's a
real fish and they really feel it's quite
powerful.
Remember you like taking
pictures of the fish for like an
excited about the,
here
we have another question.
Yes. Hello. Um, so you've talked a lot
about this, a mission behind this movie,
not just entertainment.
Um,
do you think it being a movie versus a
book or an article or some other men's,
is it going to reach more people are
going to have a different impact?
Do you think it'd being
a movie specifically?
Well that depends on people like you
buying your moving ticket on Friday,
Saturday or Sunday of this week
preferably and going, she's not getting,
we're not kidding.
I think movie,
I mean personally I think movies
have a wonderful and television. Um,
Ha has a wonderful way to uh,
create conversations about change because
I think a lot of people see them and
they see them for fun.
And,
and our goal as a team and making this
movie was to make something that is just
in and of itself an
entertaining Wall Street movie.
We really just want you to go to
the movies and enjoy the movie.
But then isn't it nice when you leave
a piece of theater or a movie or a TV
series and you have real issues
to talk about afterwards? Um,
our goal is that you just watch it
and you don't really notice that it's
starting three women directed by a woman
produced by women written by a woman.
You know,
you just watched the movie and enjoy it
and then afterwards you're like, Hey,
women can do that.
And it's a really great movie.
I think that's a really
interesting undercurrent when
watching the film is that
there's not a lot of discussion
about being a woman. Right?
It's just something that I knew of going
into watching the film. But um, it is,
there is so much there to unpack that
is covered through the some text or
through the interactions that might
not always be something that, you know,
men would pick up on in regular terms,
but because you're seeing it play out on
the big screen and it was one of those
movies,
I definitely will say it's uncomfortable
to watch because it hit really close to
home.
Um,
and it was one of those moments that
I get so frustrated and I could feel
everything that Anna was going through.
And um,
and it is really powerful
message to put out there.
And I think to digest in this platform
yet another reason why it's important to
see on the big screen, not the small
screen gone name. I just want to say
on that note of, you know, yes,
there's a here we've been asked here
today to talk about some of the themes and
the issues. But um, when I
started out as a playwright,
my brother who works in finance
actually, uh, would constantly kind of,
he would basically say to me,
he thought I was too caught up in
social issues and he thought it was,
I was prioritizing too
much in my projects,
the themes and the subject
matters that mattered to me.
And he would constantly say,
just tell a good story.
People just want to forget
whether it's environmental or the,
it's just tell it gets right. So, uh,
my brother actually came on as an investor
in this film and when he came to see
it at Sundance, he had never read the
script. He just took a leap of faith.
And when he came to see it,
I was really nervous because I
needed it to be a good story for him.
And he really, he loves the story. So
that's a vote of confidence for you.
Go ahead. Hello Amy. Now, for
some reason I want to fish.
I don't know why.
So a question for you,
Alicia and Anna. I'm so in the past, uh,
it kind of what struck me is that
you both played really strong and um,
if not polemic, a female characters
on TV, especially you, Alicia.
Holy Moly. Amazing. Um,
but I was just curious like
if those, either of those
characters that you played,
um, I'm talking about breaking bad and
orange is the new black obviously, um,
helped inform your performance or kind
of made you think about, you know,
riding the line, you know,
between like, you know,
soft and hard and strong enough to strong,
uh,
just curious if no,
then then nobody.
Well, I, I sir, I had a very, uh,
strange and interesting journey with
Skylar in terms of the sort of Skyler hate
on the Internet.
And it was a very difficult
thing to understand when
it first started happening.
Um,
I wasn't really into looking at anything
on online and I was informed about it.
And then I, as I wrote
an op Ed piece, um, uh,
towards the end of the show,
I opened Pandora's box and looked at,
you know, looked at some of it because I
wanted to understand as a, as an actor,
you want to understand if what you're
doing is not working or is rubbing people
the wrong way for some reason. And
then I started getting, I mean,
it really did parallel Naomi's journey
in so many ways because I started to
doubt myself and I started to
think, okay, what's, you know,
what should I improve or what should
I do differently? Um, and then I,
I really went through a process of
shutting it down and not looking at it
anymore. And I think there were
several reasons that it happened,
but I think we're still dealing with the,
the expectations of what a woman
should be, what her gender, you know,
gender roles, what a wife should be, what
we expect a woman to look like, to, uh,
to, to speak. Like if she's too
confident, if too, all those things.
So,
um,
I felt like I really understood
because I'd been through that.
It really informed how I played
Naomi because I'd been through that.
And I think that's why she's such a tough
person on the outside because she has
to be.
Hmm. Um, and for me,
uh,
similar journey,
you play a character like that
that's incredibly recognizable.
And I always say like,
my daughter would be on the seven.
My daughter learn the word bad ass really
early because I'd be with her and like
multiple times a day people come up to
me and they're like, Europe, bad ass.
And she's like, what's
up? You know? Um, and uh,
and similar to when we
were talking earlier,
I never saw her as a bad ass.
Like when you're in it,
you're just trying to do the best you can.
Like fig really thinks she's doing
the best she can for these women.
Like she really does in her twisted way.
Um, and let's be honest,
what happened when she left?
Not great stuff,
like she was working the system,
but she was running that place
better than he did. You know?
So just say it,
just say the woman knew
what she was doing.
So,
um,
with this I think in reference
to this piece of art,
I just want to say I was
so deeply inspired by Genji
and all the writers and all
the,
all the female directors and,
and the diversity of that
cast and that also, um,
I got to work in Shonda land after that.
It was funny because I wrote like when
we wrote our characters before we came to
Amy and, um, when I was creating
this character in my head,
I had never played, I hadn't played
a lawyer since like, you know,
five law and order as ago.
Um, which we did together.
We didn't know we were in the same
episode, didn't know each other.
Uh,
and um,
so I w I was interested in playing sort
of the opposite of fig and when we wrote
her,
like,
and I knew that I wanted to be married
to a woman and an African American woman
because I wanted to create as many roles
for women and women of Color in this
movie.
And we didn't have an answer about what,
when we first had the ideas of these
characters, we didn't know how,
how the movie would end.
So we didn't know like would she
catch the bad guy in the, I'm like,
she was the one in the white hat.
We didn't really have a sense of
where we were going with it. Um,
that's Amy's brilliance. And, um, and I,
I back to sort of full circle how fig
thinks she's doing that. You know,
Samantha things still thinks
she's going to catch the bad guys.
She's going to go and
do it a different way,
but she really still wants
to wear the white hat. Um,
so I don't know if that
answers your question at all.
Um, so we, we are running short on time,
but I just want to make sure if you guys
could summarize quickly one sentiment
from this talk that you want to make
sure that the audience has walk away from
when they see the film on the big
screen this weekend. What would it be?
Fair.
It is for women.
Your dollar.
Don't let money be a dirty word.
So the film opens up this Friday in
New York City and La, please, please,
please go see this film. It's a very
important statement and it's a great,
great story.
Um,
I'd love to thank all the Googlers for
joining the events team for kicking off a
flawless event.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.